c'est une image symbolique
un commandant de l'armée ukrainienne
piétine le drapeau russe et hisse les
couleurs de l'Ukraine les troubles
ukrainiennes ont repris la totalité de
la ville de goupillance dans la région
de quartier à l'est du pays une victoire
importante et stratégique en réponse au
plan d'annexion de Moscou
il s'agit d'un important neuf
ferroviaire qui est relié à la région de
lonsk et ensuite au système ferroviaire
russe donc évidemment en termes de
logistique et d'approvisionnement il
était important pour les Russes de
contrôler cette ville
dans la ville libérée les soldats
Ukrainiens découvrent des chats russes
éventrés des voitures criblées de balles
et des cadavres de soldats russes qui
jonchent les rues
90% des habitants avaient fui les
combats au moment de l'invasion de la
Russie les autres ont vécu l'arrivée des
troupes russes
c'était vraiment très dur nous étions
terrifiés sans eau sans électricité sans
gaz sans connexion mobile
s'aimer
en prison vous êtes arrêté tous les
trois ou quatre kilomètres à un poste de
contrôle où il vous fouille vous
dépouille littéralement jusqu'à l'os
symbole de cette reconquête ukrainienne
cette chaîne humaine pour distribuer les
2000 colis de nourriture et d'aide
humanitaires dans ces zones reprises
russes